[Música]
Paraguay celebra elecciones generales
este 30 de abril el gobernante partido
Colorado conservador enfrentará El
desafío de una amplia coalición de
Centro izquierda en el país el voto es
obligatorio para aproximadamente 4,8
millones de votantes registrados entre
18 y 75 años e incluye 80 escaños de
diputados de la cámara baja 45 escaños
del senado y 17 gobernadores sin contar
de 257 puestos de asambleas estatales
finalmente será elegido el máximo cargo
el presidente en un sistema que tiene
una sola ronda vamos al análisis de esta
elección con Katia gorostiaga ella es
docente e investigadora sobre democracia
e instituciones políticas y doctora de
investigación en ciencias sociales
además de maestra en ciencias sociales
en la facultad latinoamericana de flacso
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros Katia
Buen día Ángela Muchas gracias a vos por
la invitación a directo a América y a
Francia
De qué manera las fracturas internas en
el partido Colorado cree usted podrían
afectar a Santiago Peña que es el
candidato de esta colectividad
en Paraguay hay una particularidad en
relación con las fracturas al interior
de los partidos políticos en particular
del del partido Colorado asociación
nacional republicana Y es que
normalmente las internas partidarias
ellos llegan muy peleados Por decirlo de
alguna manera Pero cuando se acercan las
elecciones generales como estas del
domingo suelen aliarse a través del algo
que se le llama el abrazo republicano
entonces sí Yo creo que el partido
Colorado llega fraccionado menos de lo
cual se nota pero más de lo que es en
realidad entonces creo que puede haber
algún tipo de incidencia en ese sentido
en estas elecciones
no quiere decir que lleguen lo
suficientemente
distantes como para no votar a favor del
partido sobre todo me refiero al voto
duro del partido
Bueno entonces vamos a hablar de los dos
candidatos que encabezan las encuestas
Por supuesto que además están muy cerca
y las encuestas también son un poco
confusas no porque hay distintos datos
Entonces está Santiago Peña este
economista de 44 años que representa
como decíamos al partido Colorado y
Efraín alegre de 60 años que lidera esta
gran coalición opositora de Centro
izquierda como se le está llamando Esta
es una democracia muy joven no hace
mucho salió de la dictadura y además el
Paraguay es un país profundamente
conservador así las cosas usted como ve
el panorama para cada uno de los
candidatos es difícil digamos en en esta
democracia hacer un cambio de ruta
evidentemente si tienes en cuenta la
historia paraguaya y la juventud de la
Democracia es difícil hacer un cambio un
cambio de ruta
a ver la democracia entró Paraguay en el
año 89 es el retorno de la democracia y
desde ese Entonces hasta ahora hubo un
solo candidato
opositor Al partido Colorado que logró
llegar a la Silla presidencial sin
embargo no logró terminar el mandato me
refiero a a Fernando Lugo verdad que fue
depuesto por un juicio político de
dudosa legalidad Entonces el cambio del
signo político todavía se ve muy difícil
en Paraguay
además bueno pensando en este cambio de
ruta como le he llamado yo en esta
entrevista que sería eventual una
eventual victoria de alegre usted cuál
cree que serían sus principales retos
precisamente para romper esta hegemonía
del partido Colorado con el 76 años en
el poder
el principal reto que yo creo que va a
tener Efraín Alegre en el caso de
resultar victorioso este domingo va a
ser la gobernabilidad Porque primero
porque él llega a través de una
concertación que aglutina partidos
políticos de las más diferentes
ideologías escuché que le llamaste de
Centro izquierda pero no es tanto así
porque si vemos el partido liberal el
partido liberal en un partido de centro
de derecha en realidad el tema está al
interior de la concertación hay
movimientos y partidos políticos de
centro y de centro de izquierda además
de los de centro de derecha eso es uno
de los retos que va a tener que
tener si en caso de que resulte
victorioso el otro que va a tener va a
ser la gobernabilidad en relación con el
poder legislativo Por qué Porque
históricamente el partido Colorado
siempre ha tenido por lo menos la
primera minoría en el congreso eso
significa que al momento de gobernar no
solo va a tener que conseguir el apoyo
de sus propios partidarios sino también
del partido Colorado para poder pasar
leyes y sobre todo ciertas leyes que
implican muchas reformas al interior del
Paraguay Entonces yo creo que estos son
los dos desafíos fundamentales que va a
tener alegre me gusta mucho que hable
sobre la composición de esta coalición
de Centro izquierda porque hay quienes
dicen que en realidad los candidatos que
se enfrentan o los que tienen digamos
más posibilidades de ganar porque claro
son 13 en total Pero estos dos
principales candidatos no representan
realmente unos movimientos tan
diferentes entre sí y no estamos
hablando propiamente de una derecha de
una izquierda sino que hay quienes dicen
que esto es es la derecha versus la
derecha y que es difícil diversificar la
política en Paraguay entonces usted ve
que realmente sí puede existir un cambio
en la forma de gobernar o está todavía
lejos Paraguay de pensar otras maneras y
otras corrientes políticas
yo creo que ya tuvimos otra forma de
gobernar recientemente pero sí como
dicen que es como como comentan que es
de la derecha contra la derecha podría
decirse que sí pero con
matizadas ambas verdad por un lado un
partido que históricamente ha gobernado
y ya tiene prácticas políticas
costumbres políticas muy claras algunas
más legales que otras contra un partido
que
digamos que presenta propuestas más
claras creo yo por lo menos y creo que
al estar compuesto por por partidos y
movimientos de diferente índoles
necesariamente va a buscar una nueva
forma de gobernar O sea no es una
cuestión de capricho no más de una nueva
forma de gobernar es una necesidad para
asegurarse la gobernabilidad Y eso se
vio recientemente en el propio gabinete
que Efraín alegre presentó en un avance
el gabinete presidencial que
presentó donde Ninguno de los candidatos
o ninguna de las personas que él propuso
como
como en las primeras magistraturas del
ejecutivo son necesariamente líderes
históricos del partido liberal hay gente
de Patria querida hay gente del partido
liberal obviamente pero incluso hay
gente del propio partido Colorado
Entonces se ve como que hay un abanico
de posibilidades diferentes en el caso
de que gane Efraín pues Mire ya nos
quedamos en tiempo Lamentablemente nos
queda para la reflexión la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Paraguay y cómo
estos avances se verán mermados o no por
una nueva presidencia que deberá abordar
Por ejemplo los derechos de las mujeres
que son un reclamo cada vez más fuerte
en el país Pese a que los últimos
movimientos lo que hicieron fue minar un
poco la participación política para
estas elecciones de esto seguramente
tendremos más tiempo para conversar en
nuestros especiales y en el cubrimiento
que hará 24 de esta jornada electoral
esa de Katia gorostiaga
cente investigadora sobre democracia e
instituciones políticas gracias a usted
Muchas gracias Ángela Vamos a continuar
en directo América hacemos una pequeña
pausa pero ya volvemos con más
[Música]